los accionistas de total Energy
aprobaron la nueva estrategia climática
del grupo petrolero mientras decenas de
activistas intentaban bloquear la
reunión el texto incluye una mayor
inversión en energías renovables y
refuerza los objetivos de reducción de
emisiones de CO2 sin embargo el grupo
rechazó la resolución presentada por
varios accionistas que pedía a total
alinear sus objetivos con el acuerdo de
París para limitar el calentamiento
global a uno coma cinco grados por
encima de los niveles preindustriales lo
que supondría una reducción acelerada de
las emisiones
de administración también considera que
la resolución propuesta por este grupo
de inversores es contraria a los
intereses de los accionistas implica una
estrategia de reducción que obligaría a
total energys a vender activos a otros
actores
los manifestantes fueron recibidos por
los gases lacrimógenos de las fuerzas de
la orden y se estos
hoy Total no tiene conciencia climática
intentan que total bote un plan
climático que es Sencillamente
escandaloso el grupo francés está
implicado en numerosos proyectos de gas
y petróleo entre ellos el proyecto del
oleoducto eacop en tanzania y uganda que
provocó el desplazamiento de más de
100.000 personas toda la argumenta que
la demanda por petróleo en el mundo va
en aumento Por lo cual seguirá
produciendo el grupo es también
críticado por sus beneficios récord de
20.500 millones de dólares en 2022